Anna British go morning her late uncle
Alexei he was 39 years old when he was
killed on the Maidan he leaves behind an
eight-year-old son he was fighting for
idea she wanted to be a part of your
opinion Union she wanted me like all the
rest of it normal countries you know she
was fighting for idea she gave his life
for idea up to 100 people were killed in
the protests most in Kiev the
circumstances are under investigation
now that the 40 days of mourning decreed
by Orthodox tradition have passed people
have come to pay their last respects
should nativa which is a hibblen we
drusy my friends were shot here that's
why I have a hard time talking about it
all of us who survived must stop their
deaths from being in vain times are hard
that we have to work for change I looked
silly when I look at our country I'm
just not sure the new government isn't
quite what I was hoping for Crimea has
been lost and no one has punished the
corrupt politicians surely mortgages
mortgage broker oopsies no problema ng I
have no idea what will come with us cuz
I people never was darkness but you Ryan
was not crushed shirt or even put their
everyone in the Maidan is determined to
continue the fight for a better future
on behalf of their loved ones